robert is so fantastic to see you here
at London filming comic-con what are you
most looking forward to about this
weekend I love London and I I just love
being able to meet the fans here and and
this is one of the largest ones I've
ever been to I was at one a couple years
ago and you need you know lots of crazy
different kinds of people here and
that's that's really the fun thing and
then doing the autographs the autographs
is a lot of fun we've got coming up for
you a very big film franchise haven't
we've got invention it because I know
we've got fans out there who want to do
Mockingjay The Hunger Games part 1 and
part 2 now everyone's a bit bit cryptic
because your characters antonius yous
not in the books well first of all I
have to I have to you'll see a
disclaimer that grows across my face at
the moment that says I can't talk about
this because the old adage I'd have to
kill you or they'd have to kill you
I mentioned that film once what I was
doing press for something and I don't
know how I got back to me but I did and
they said can't talk about it
can't talk about it it's a beautiful
secret and trust me it's it's gonna be
great keeping that secret thanks I'm
sure I mean it's such a big look really
hard it's kind of like you know knowing
that I've got this great little
Christmas present and I can't tell you
about it but yeah now they're they're
very they're very tight about it
obviously it's such a huge phenomenon
based as a book and it's the films The
Hunger Games why do you think it's been
so popular I think I mean I started in
the theater years ago and it's it's it's
great storytelling 101 it's it's just a
beautiful that first book I'll never
forget it and that first movie and the
second movie was terrific and I can only
expect that the third one will be as
well it always starts with the word and
and that story and the writers they have
on that are amazing to transform that
book into into cinema so you can add all
the pyrotechnics you want we got a few
of them sitting outside here today you
know but if you don't have a great story
to go with it you're screwed you don't
you're not gonna it's not gonna
transcend time do you think it is about
the people who've played in the first
two movies the characters you know
Jennifer Lawrence it's really caught
people's imaginations yeah and you know
again great casting but really just
adding on to what the story was it is
they just they just fit they just really
fit I mean you look at any great movie
television show stage play and you and
you think that is the perfect person to
play that part no one else could have
played that party you hear about other
choices down the road that you know
might have been the person for that part
you know now I don't see that person
putting that part so you know you've
done it you've done it right of course
also we've seen you in arrow relatively
recently haven't we you clock King
tockman and what was it like being part
of that universe that as an actor is
that is the best thing to play because
you you just use your imagination you
have no I had no time to prepare for
that my wife actually was the one who
actually said oh you know this is a
pretty is a pretty great character from
in history of different kinds of
interpretations of it so yeah that was a
lot of fun flying by the seat of my
pants coming up with that and of course
we could see you back at some point do
you think you'd like to go back to air
oh yeah no I'd love to come back on that
look i-i've never I don't think I've
ever had a job play character where I
wouldn't want to come back even if the
guy was dead I'd love to come back tell
us a little bit about the fun of kind of
going into a world like that kind of
dipping your toe in and kind of working
with the actors who established on that
show yeah you really you know as an
actor I always learned if you're gonna
play a part play a great part Thank You
Bilaspur
and Northwestern University it really is
it's boring playing just a normal guy
you know I I just I don't know how to do
it anyway I try to live it in my real
life but I don't know how to do it on
film so it's it's always you're just
like you're just going to like I have a
my boy now is 12 years old and I always
feel like I'm a little boy going to work
you know what do you do today oh I just
like I'm shooting this huge miniseries
down in Mexico right now called Texas
rising about the formation of Texas back
in the 1830s it's not a typical normal
you know thing you go to work to do
every day Errol what do you do they oh I
wore like 12 different clocks on my body
and I was mad that my sister's sick and
I got a you know seek vengeance I mean
it's it's just you know not the normal
mode but come Dano kind of thing I just
make a plug for Hawaii five-o now that I
said book him Danno that's another show
I loved working on I just did it last
year and they're trying to work it out
that I can come back next year and book
him Danno was you know that was one of
my favorite shows as a kid and Here I am
as an adult getting to work on it it's
it's so much fun
talking about going back of course we've
seen it recently
Ishod announced us heroes is coming back
heroes reborn from any various oh no
what's up with euros I've heard that but
I don't know if they're teasing us or
not I'll let you know what I find out
for sure I'm not sure how much would you
like to kind of go back to that world
again it's a it's a beautiful world it's
very imaginative the world great people
to work with and just kind of ended
before it's time so yeah it would be it
would be great to go back you could go
back and they said - you can do whatever
you want what would you like to do is
your character because he was a great
character wasn't he that a carnival
leader
Wow I'm always as a actor I say I'm not
a writer I'm a suggestor oh I don't know
I don't know what else they could do
with him he he really I don't imagine he
would start out sort of like sir Ian's
character you know and be locked up
somewhere he'd have to figure out how to
use somebody in their powers to be able
to create that power again to be able to
move earth or move a cell door opening
up something like that
heroes was interesting for me because I
just finished up my four-year stint on
Prison Break and I really I grew up with
a dad who hated television so it kind of
engrained in me never to watch TV
I watched it because of my son wants
them all especially was younger but I I
didn't really know the show to follow it
like a lot of the fans here know it I
just walked into a world of saying wow
there's an interesting guy who's you
know pissed off at his brother and he
didn't mean to kill him but oops
he threw the thing too much through his
throat and it killed him and and now
he's a bad guy and my son gave me the
best compliment on that he said pop I'm
not sure he watched like three or four
episodes I'm not sure are you a good guy
on this or a bad guy and I thought yes
we're doing
because that's nice when you've got that
kind of blurring of the lines husband
isn't it I think what the carrier takes
it's more complex more interesting for
you as an actor as well and the audience
too yeah I mean again going back to
training days you never play a bad guy
like a bad guy you never play a good guy
like a good guy and a lot of parts now
written that are on the edge of being
darker characters or soulless characters
that they are the shades of gray are
pretty pretty amazing to be able to play
those I thank God can we look forward to
coming up next to me I did a great
series last year called mob city I just
did one season of it with Frank Darabont
Eddie burns who played Bugsy Siegel on
that has a new series called public
morals we start shooting that in
February and February it comes on I
think in February I was starting that in
October and because of Eddie Steven
Spielberg is producing that show and
fingers crossed I'm going to be working
with Steven soon on his next movie so
we'll see Steven please hire me a little
bit about some public morals you
mentioned the new show Eddie's really
great with writing about his family and
cops and his family and this is one that
he had kind of in the drawer that he
told me that he hadn't shot yet it's a
1960s vice squad cops in New York City
and I play there their captain very
different character that I've played
before which I love I love the chameleon
kind of quality of stuff great great
script kind of reminds me of somebody
like Sidney Lumet would have loved to
get his hands on Pacino what a lot it's
a very 60s a very 70s kind of style
great storytelling in this this world
happens to be with with cops
it's great usually I play you know the
guy on the other side oh that's good
finally what would you like to say to
your fans out there Robert it's just a
huge thank you and and it's always
amazing to me because I you know when
you shoot something you you're in a very
insulated kind of environment it's just
you and the crew and the other actors
the director and it's amazing that it's
that it reverberates in to them and and
actually transcends time that's you know
Prison Break was years ago but here
especially Paris actually major cities
around the world capital cities that
that show is still resonating for so
many people and that's good to know
it's good to hear thank you
you